-Voici l'arsenal trouvé par
les policiers dans la voiture
du forcené de Béziers.
Malgré les barrages,
son complice court toujours.
Les armes de guerres ont-elles fait
leurs apparitions dans les cités ?
Des éléments de réponses
dans un instant. Première journée
test pour les couloirs de bus
fermés à Paris.
Apparemment, les bouchons
sont restés limités.
Trois questions, ce soir, à
Bertrand Delanoë, le maire de Paris.
L'affaire des anticholestérols.
Le laboratoire allemand
a multiplié cadeaux et pressions
sur les médecins pour les inciter
à prescrire le médicament
aujourd'hui retiré.
On l'appelait Le Petit Prince,
Patrice Martin,
enfant prodige du ski nautique
qui a tout gagné pendant 20 ans,
arrête la compétition.
Vous entendrez sa confirmation.
Bonsoir. Merci de votre attention.
Direction Béziers pour commencer.
Presque 2 jours après la fusillade
qui a fait un mort,
ce sont des actes de guerre comme
en Palestine ou en ex-Yougoslavie.
Voilà ce que déclare le maire
de la ville, Raymond Couderc.
Les policiers cherchent le complice
et s'interrogent sur le mobile
de ce coup de folie.
Bonjour. Flash spécial
pour vous annoncer
ces spectaculaires explosions.
Ce serait un attentat,
selon les médias américains,
à New York, au cœur de Manhattan.
Vous découvrez l'image.
En 20 mn, 2 avions ont percutés
les prestigieuses tours jumelles
du World Trade Center,
dans le quartier de Wall Street,
à 8h45, heure américaine.
Les tours sont en feu.
Pas de bilan pour l'instant.
On parle de plusieurs morts
et des dizaines de blessés,
car à ce moment de la journée,
ces bureaux du quartier
de Wall Street sont déjà
bien sûr occupés.
Bonsoir. Il est 14h à New York.
Edition spéciale.
Soirée spéciale Etats-Unis
presque une semaine
après les attentats.
Bonsoir à tous.
8 jours après, c'est certitude.
le ras-de-marée en Asie du Sud
est bien la plus grande catastrophe
naturelle de l'histoire récente.
Edition spéciale, ce soir,
France Télévisions,
avec la Fondation de France,
mobilise ses équipes,
pour entretenir les soutiens
aux pays et vous informer.
Un élan massif, dans les écoles,
dans les entreprises,
dans les prisons.
35 millions d'euros ont été
recueillis par les associations.
Du jamais vu
en si peu de temps.
Nous l'évoquerons avec nos invités,
l'abbé Pierre et Bernard Kouchner.
Aux Etats-Unis,
Georges Bush a chargé son père
et son prédécesseur Bill Clinton
de récolter des fonds.
Bonsoir. Dans l'actualité ce soir,
les terribles conséquences
de la tempête,
dans l'ouest de la France.
On compte 59 morts et disparus.
La plupart noyés dans leurs maisons,
en Vendée, en Charente-Maritime.
Les pompiers cherchent des rescapés.
Les dégâts sont énormes.
Des milliers d'habitations
sont encore sous les eaux.
On sait que plusieurs digues ont
été submergées le long des côtes.
Nicolas Sarkozy
s'est rendu sur les lieux.
Il a promis une aide de 3 millions
d'euros, et on s'interroge déjà
sur les règles d'urbanisation.
Images, reportages, témoignages.
Nos équipes sont sur place.
Nous serons en direct avec
nos envoyés spéciaux et nos invités
et nous essaierons de comprendre
ce qui s'est passé exactement.
Bienvenue
dans cette édition spéciale.
Il y a un jour et demi,
la tempête balayait la France,
et ce n'est qu'aujourd'hui
qu'on mesure pleinement l'impact.
Ces images ont été tournées
cette après-midi
et on réalise à quel point l'océan
est entré dans les terres.
Les rues, les routes,
les jardins, les résidences
sont encore noyés.
Et dans plusieurs zones du littoral,
le niveau de l'eau ne diminue pas
en raison d'une nouvelle grande marée.
Le pompage commence à peine.
On reste encore
dans une situation d'urgence.
Les plans aériens que nous
a envoyé Alain Darrigrand.
Devons-nous redouter le nucléaire ?
Vous avez sans doute votre opinion.
La question n'est pas nouvelle
mais elle resurgit brusquement
avec cette tragédie japonaise.
Que nous apprend-elle
sur les fragilités de la filière ?
C'est l'un des enjeux
de l'édition de ce soir.
-Le journal de 20 h,
David Pujadas.
-Bonsoir. Au sommaire
de ce journal spécial :
le Japon demande l'aide,
des experts internationaux face
à la menace nucléaire.
Une 2e explosion
s'est produite
dans la centrale de Fukushima.
Le système de refroidissement
d'un troisième réacteur est en panne.
L'accident pourrait passer
du niveau 4 au niveau 5 ou 6.
Images, reportages et une invitée,
Anne Lauvergeon, présidente d'Areva.
Dans la foulée, plusieurs pays
européens ont décidé de geler
leurs programmes nucléaires.
Quelles sécurités ?
Quelles risques ?
On y reviendra avec un débat
entre Claude Allègre
et Daniel Cohn-Bendit.
Bonsoir à tous.
La France frappée,
la France blessée. 12 morts,
4 blessés dans un état grave.
L'attaque contre Charlie Hebdo
est l'attentat le plus meurtrier
depuis plus de 50 ans.
Parmi les victimes,
4 dessinateurs,
Cabu, Wolinski, Chab, Tignous,
l'économiste Bernard Maris
et 2 policiers.
Des terroristes lourdement armés
qui sont toujours en fuite.
Des centaines d'hommes
sont à leurs trousses.
De grands rassemblements sont
en cours dans les grandes villes.
Le plan Vigipirate est au maximum
en Ile-de-France.
Les grands magasins, les lieux de
culte et les transports publiques
sont placés
sous protection renforcée.
Edition spéciale
sur cette journée noire
pour la presse et pour la France,
avec nos envoyés spéciaux
et de nombreux invités,
pour évoquer cette épreuve
et cette nouvelle donne
pour le pays.
Le président de la République
s'adressera aux Français
à l'Elysée,
où les drapeaux sont en berne.
Bonjour à tous.
Le jour se lève.
La France a été frappée
de façon inédite par le terrorisme.
Inédite par l'ampleur,
puisqu'on parle
d'un bilan d'au moins 120 morts.
Inédit par le mode opératoire,
car plusieurs attaques terroristes
6 ou 7 au total,
la plupart à Paris, l'autre,
ou les autres, au Stade de France,
autour du Stade de France,
se sont donc produites hier soir,
il y a à peine 9 heures.
-Le journal de 20 h, David Pujadas.
-Bonsoir à tous,
dans l'actualité ce soir,
nous évoquerons d'abord
notre enquête
sur "le manger au restaurant".
On reste dans l'économie
et le social.
Vous le constatez,
cette intrusion sur le plateau
des intermittents du spectacle.
Nous avons décidé de leur laisser
la parole, une minute,
pour exprimer leurs revendications.
Je vous laisse la place.
Allez-y. Prenez mon siège.
Et nous vous écoutons.
Ou plutôt adressez-vous.
Ici, le micro.
Et nous vous écoutons...
-Merci.
-Voila. Petit soucis
avec cette occupation du plateau.
Nous rendons l'antenne. Nous ne
pouvons pas faire ce journal.
Non, je suis très calme.
Je te dis juste...
tu m'informes, tu...
Bien.
-Je voulais vous dire
que vous m'avez bluffé.
Vous racontez des choses dures,
mais toujours avec la "bogossité".
Le costume parallèle à la table,
la coupe faite par Mackintosh.
Ne changez rien.
Après Rachid Arhab, je me disais :
"Qui ils vont nous mettre ?"
Ne changez rien.
C'est tout ce que j'ai à vous dire.
-Est-ce que vous avez
une extra-mémoire ?
-Question accablante, habituellement.
-C'est bien ce que je disais.
-Non, pas du tout.
Vous êtes Espagnol aussi,
comme dans le film ?
-D'origine, oui.
Comme "Les femmes du 6e étage".
-Un million et demi,
c'est un miracle.
Quand vous faites
une représentation de 2 h,
où vous essayez de ne pas trahir
l'altitude, la puissance,
la beauté du langage.
Et quelqu'un vous dit :
"Oh putain ! Quelle mémoire !"
Tu as l'impression
que c'est futile,
car on peut imaginer des acteurs
avec beaucoup de mémoire
qui soient très rasoirs.
-On s'interroge.
-Vous comprenez le français ?
Je ne répondrai à aucune question.
C'est mon 20 heures,
ce n'est pas ton 20 heures.
Faites quelque chose
que vous n'avez jamais fait.
Prenez un café.
-Restez là, Jamel !
-Je savais que vous alliez
insister avec vos questions.
Prenez un café.
Aucun présentateur du JT
n'a pris un café à 20 h.
-C'est sympa. Vous voulez
que je prenne un peu de repos...
-Exactement !
-Il y a un café pour vous aussi.
-J'ai tout prévu.
Comment ça va la famille, David ?
-Ca va pas mal, mais c'est à vous
que j'ai envie de poser la question.
-Je ne répondrai pas.
-Que voulez-vous dire ?
-Parlez-nous de vous.
A force de présenter des mauvaises
nouvelles, vous ne rentrez pas
chez vous énervé ?
-Ca dépend. Ce soir, il y avait la
victoire des handballeurs français
et la fête sur les Champs-Elysées.
Il y a trop de mauvaises nouvelles ?
-C'est mon sentiment.
Et ça me fait
mal au coeur pour vous.